In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 16 on which we commemorate our Holy Father
Siprian metropolitan of Kiev and all Russia.
Our Holy Father Siprian was born in Trnovo into a noble Bulgarian family in the year 1330.
He entered the monastery of Califarevo, the center of the Hessecast revival in Bulgaria.
There St. Theldosios, the illustrious disciple of St. Gregory of Sinai, guided his first steps
in the spiritual life.
Siprian became the friend of St. Ethemios, the future patriarch of Trnovo.
Even wanting to drink at the source, he made his way to Constantinople and settled in
the studio monastery, where he gave much attention to copying manuscripts.
His ability was recognized by the patriarch St. Philothios, who took him into his service
as Sincelos and counselor.
When Philothios was deposed for the first time in the year 1354, St. Siprian accompanied
him to mount Athos.
There in the very places made holy by the Hessecast saints, he was zealous in his devotion
to inner prayer, adding there too, as a faithful disciple of St. Theldosios, the labor of translating
the works of the Greek fathers into Slavonic and of transcribing service books.
His ascetic struggles ardent prayer, constant meditation on the word of God and habit of
humbly asking counsel of the elders on every matter, enabled him to gain a deep understanding
of spiritual things, joined to a vast knowledge of Holy Scripture and of the fathers of the
church.
While on the Holy Mountain he compiled several theological works that contributed to making
the teaching of St. Gregory Palamas and his successors, known in the Slav lands.
In St. Philothios resumed the patriarchal throne in the year 1364, he summoned Siprian
to Constantinople to assist him in matters to do with the Slav churches.
In this capacity he probably contributed to the negotiations that resulted in the restoration
of communion with the Church of Serbia in the year 1368 and 1371.
And with the Church of Bulgaria in the year 1375, both churches had taken advantage of
the weakness of the empire to set themselves up as independent patriarchates.
At the same time, Ullgurd, the still pagan prince of Lithuania, many of whose subjects were
Orthodox Christians, applied to the ecumenical patriarch for the appointment of a metropolitan
of Kiev, with jurisdiction over the principalities of Smolensk and Tver.
This would set the seal in ecclesiastical terms upon Ullgurd's claim to equality with Moscow,
the metropolitan sea of St. Alexis, whom Ullgurd accused of neglecting the Orthodox people
of his principality.
Ullgurd was pursuing the same policy as Prince Casimir of Poland, who obtained a metropolitan
for Galicia from the patriarch by threatening to turn to the Catholics if he did not get
his way.
In his concern to maintain the unity of the Russian Church, in which he saw the promise
of a brilliant future, patriarch Philothios sent Cyprian as his legate, Apokrisadios.
To the prince of Lithuania, in order to mend relations between him and metropolitan Alexis,
to the pressing demands of Ullgurd and his renewed threats to convert to Catholicism, the
patriarch responded by a compromise.
In the year 1376 he appointed Cyprian as metropolitan of Lithuania and designated him
successor to the aged Alexis as sole metropolitan of the Russian Church.
The new metropolitan soon won the confidence of Ullgurd and from his sea at Kiev set to work
to revive church life in Lithuania, amending evil customs, ordaining priests and evangelizing
the pagans.
Upon the death of St. Alexis in the year 1378 Cyprian set out for Moscow to take possession
of the metropolitan sea as St. Philothios had stipulated, but before ever he reached the city,
he was arrested, ill-treated, and imprisoned in a cold, dank dungeon on the orders of
Grand Prince Demetri Donscoy, who regarded him as a Lithuanian spy.
On his return to Kiev, Cyprian wrote to St. Surgis of Radones, and to his nephew St. Theodor
of Simonov, setting out the facts and insisting upon his loyalty to the Grand Prince and attachment
to the principality of Moscow, clearly shown during his residence at Kiev when he had secured
the freedom of Muscovite prisoners.
He then set out for Constantinople where he found everything in confusion, both politically
and ecclesiastically.
In place of St. Philothios, the emperor had intruded Makarios as Patriarch in the years 1376 through
1379, who informed Cyprian that he intended to appoint Archimandrite Michael Mityati as
metropolitan of all Russia.
On the death of Alexis, this tyrannical anti-monastic clergyman had taken over the metropolitan's
residence in Moscow, and dawned pontifical ornaments, although not a bishop.
Makarios summoned him to Constantinople for consecration, but Mityati died on the way,
within sight, of the city.
The clergy traveling with him carried blank letters addressed to the Patriarch, and signed
by the Grand Prince for use in this contingency.
They agreed to present Piemann, one of their number, as the Grand Prince's candidate.
The Patriarch Nilos Geramios, in the years 1380 through 1388, who had just succeeded Makarios,
and who was unaware of the situation in Russia, consecrated Piemann without further inquiry,
thus confirming the division of the Russian Church that St. Philothios had striven so hard
to prevent.
After the glorious victory of Kulikovo, on the 8th of September in the year 1380, that marked
the beginning of freedom from the Tatar Yoke, Prince Dmitri bearing in mind that St. Cyprian
had assisted the outcome of the fight, in prevailing with Prince Giello, of Lithuania,
not to support the Taters, took the advice of Thelphanus of Nysia and St. Surgis, and sent
St. Theodore of Simonov to invite St. Cyprian to assume the Metropolitan Sea of the re-unified
Russian land.
St. Cyprian entered Moscow on the 23rd of May in the year 1381, and amid popularly
rejoicing, Prince Dmitri publicly asked his forgiveness.
Soon afterwards, Cyprian composed the Eulogy of St. Peter of Moscow, noting similarities
with his own life, and he glorified St. Alexander Nevsky to symbolize the unity of the Russian
Church.
But the situation soon changed for the worse.
The Taters allied with the Eastern Mongols attacked Moscow in the following year, and
wreaked havoc wherever they came.
Prince Dmitri was exceedingly angry on learning that Metropolitan Cyprian had taken refuge
in the hostile city of Tver, and decided to depose him as head of the Church in favor
of Pemen, whom he brought out of prison.
Following the ways of Providence, St. Cyprian returned once again to Kiev, but the extortionate
and generally unbecoming conduct of Pemen soon led to his disgrace, and the Grand Prince
appealed against him to the Patriarch, who summoned both Pemen and Cyprian to Constantinople,
where the permanent synod would deal with their respective claims.
And theodore of Simunov went a little in advance of Cyprian to the city, bearing the message
that the Grand Prince refused absolutely to accept Pemen as Metropolitan.
The Emperor took advantage of St. Cyprian's presence in Constantinople to send him on a diplomatic
mission to the Principality of Lithuania that had become joined to the Kingdom of Poland
in a Dynastic Union represented by Giello.
On becoming sovereign of the two states, Giello converted to Catholicism, which jeopardized
the future of orthodoxy in the western parts of Russia.
After Cyprian's return to Constantinople, Antony, the new Patriarch in the years 1389-1390
and 1391-1397, deposed Pemen who had refused to appear before the synod and confirmed Cyprian
as Metropolitan of Kiev and all Russia.
But it was not until the death of Prince Dimitri, followed soon after that of Pemen in
the year 1389, that the saint was able to return to Moscow, where Prince Basil Dimitrivić
and all the people received him as their spiritual father.
His kindness and charitable spirit showed in his willingness to recognize the clergy ordained
by Pemen, but his ecclesiastical policy was that of St. Philotheos, namely to make Moscow
the center of the Russian Church and faithful heir to the civilization of New Rome.
He put into effect the liturgical reforms of St. Philotheos, made the practice of the Church
of Constantinople the rule for the Church of Russia, and added to the synodicone of orthodoxy
the clauses relating to the doctrine of St. Gregory Palamas on the uncreated energies.
On several occasions, he oversaw the collection of money for the needs of Constantinople, particularly
during the siege of the city of Baja Set in the year 1394.
And so, having governed his church in wisdom and set it on the glorious path that lay before
it, St. Cyprian fell asleep in peace on the 16th of September in the year 1406.
Four days before his departure, he dictated a letter to be read at his funeral, in which
he humbly begged forgiveness of friends and enemies alike, and embracing them in the Lord
gave his blessing to all.
This letter was also read at the funerals of several of his successors.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, of mercy on us,
and save us.